hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
throughout his work all things are
possible and really throughout
his corpus as a whole you're going to
see lev shestoff
talking at at a number of different
places about ultimate realities
and questions and sometimes he'll use
other phrasing as well for example
in part 1 chapter 28 where he tells us
that literature deals with the most
difficult and important problems of
existence so it's not always exactly the
same formulation but we are talking
about
things that are most basic and really
inescapable
so talking about existential questions
is a good way to get at it and and some
some of the things that
we might consider ultimate questions
might be viewed as
not all that existential not just about
us but about the cosmos as a whole but
if we look at them in the right light
they are also
existential so if you think about what
some of the
ones that he mentions in this work
are he talks about you know
understanding
or knowing life that's
one of the fundamental questions people
come to an intro to philosophy class
and they they come in and say what what
is the meaning of life
and then the philosopher said well you
know there's a lot of different answers
to that
well which one is it and that's an
ultimate question that we
we really can't evade but we also can't
answer in some sort of
general sense that's going to convince
everybody
whether we have freedom or not what we
ought to do with our freedom that's a
fundamental
philosophical question as well some
people have devoted entire careers to
arguing that we have it or don't have it
or just in this way he's going to also
talk about
a fundamental problem of justice
that is a really central one and
you know it does bedevil a number of
people
the nature of the universe itself you
know
all the different things in it is it
bounded is it not
these metaphysical questions even the
the question
of the scope of human rationality
or reason maybe there's a reason with a
capital r
writ large that's the mind of god or
some cosmic logos or maybe
everything is totally irrationality what
is the nature of our human reason
in relation to this and we could add
other things how should society be
organized
all the things that we talk about as the
big questions
when we're introducing people to
philosophy we often give them a hope
that well if you just study philosophy
you're going to get the answers to these
and you will indeed get answers but they
may not be
the answers and shust off is
as you're going to see rather a skeptic
he does talk about why it is that people
think that philosophy
or other things that are doing similar
work
like literature are going to provide us
with these answers and i should pause
here for a moment
if we say that philosophy can't answer
these questions or can't address these
questions
that does not satisfy the demand on
people's part
for some answer to these so a philosophy
for a while
abandons its pretenses to
delve into and to study these well then
the sciences will
or you know whether the natural sciences
or the social sciences
or other you know attitudes and
projects will come along and say we've
got the answer and there will be people
ready
to pick it up could be a political
platform
and program it could be some other
social doctrine it could be a religion
people want answers to the these
questions
and so in uh chapter 38 of part one
he talks about something that he
attributes to the russians but i think
we could say
this is actually a perennial issue he
says a strange impatience has taken
possession of russian writers lately
they're all running a race after the
ultimate words
they have no doubt that the ultimate
words will be attained the question is
who will lay hold of them first
and so when you're in you might call it
a
saturated environment where people think
that there's
you know the answer is right around the
corner we just have to find it
it lets it creates a certain kind of
credulity
on the part of those who take things
seriously and
want to find answers they think yeah i'm
just going to
go here and i'll get the answer and they
often flip from answer to answer to
answer to answer
sort of like the youths that he talks
about later on in part two
as moving from you know positivism to
conscientism to this to that
there's a reason why people do that
there's a reason why people leave
religion
and then become atheists and get into
all sorts of skeptic forums and then
you know after they've done some
crusading for that they abandon that
and find some other thing and slip into
new age thought or whatever it is
that they're going to do they get
politically involved and start you know
talking about all sorts of things on the
left or the right as if these have
ultimate importance there's another
thing that that goes on
though and he talks about this in uh
chapter
45 almost near the end of part two
he's talking about the the russian
spirit
and again you know we i think we can ask
are we
is this just about russia and europe at
the time or could we talk about this
in our own cultural situation and he
says
while european thinkers have for
centuries been beating their brains over
insoluble problems
we've only just begun to try our powers
so we could think about this in terms of
like you know what the cultural elites
have been doing
and then what the rest of us the masses
have been doing those of us who didn't
come from an academic or cultured
background
and he says that we don't have any
failures behind us
so we don't actually see quite quite
what's going on
other people's experience is not ours we
are not bound by their
conclusions and he says the most
skeptical russian hides a hope at the
bottom of his soul
hence our fearless fearlessness of the
truth realistic truth
which is so stunned european critics
right he says the westerner is
self-reliant he knows that if he doesn't
help himself no one will help him
so he directs all his thoughts to making
the best of his opportunities
the russian has a different sort of
point of view he says um
here we go um a russian believes he can
do anything
hence he's afraid of of nothing so he
thinks that you know
we can attain these ultimate truths
whereas other people might be uh
we should be skeptical of this you know
and he's got this great passage here
where he talks about a kind of uh
rhetoric here we go
says our confident truthfulness like
european rhetoric turns out
to be beyond truth and falsehood he's
echoing
nietzsche's beyond good and evil in that
case the young
east and the old west suffer from the
restrictions imposed by truth
but the former ignores the restrictions
while the latter adapts itself
to them so this is these are possible
ways to address these hopes and demands
for resolutions of
ultimate realities why does philosophy
come to think
that it has reached them and is able to
supply
them to people that is another question
that is that is being dealt with here
um we look at chapter 111 of part one
where he tells us that every
philosophical world conception
starts from some or other solution of
the general problem
of human existence and proceeds from
this to direct the course of human life
in some particular direction
or another so every philosophy he
justif has a view of philosophy as
largely oriented
by our existential condition and the
situations that we find ourselves in
telling us that that you know very often
philosophy thinks that it's completely
autonomous and completely rational but
it's really being driven
by other things and now notice what it's
doing it's starting out from
the the existential situation that we're
in where we're puzzled about ultimate
realities
and then it tries to provide us with
some sort of solution
uh shustaff tells us we have neither the
power nor the data for the solution of
general problems
because of this all our moral deductions
are arbitrary they witness to our
prejudices
if we're naturally timid or our
propensities and taste if we're
self-confident
so you know this is this is saying that
philosophy is not as general
as it claims to be if we look at
chapter 41 of part two there's another
very interesting discussion about
metaphysical
consolations where he says that the more
that you piece to the ultimate
pierce to the ultimate ends of the
infinite metaphysical problems the more
finite they reveal themselves why do
people engage
in metaphysics in exploring the
fundamental
questions because they want answers and
they want answers that will
satisfy them in some way and so
metaphysical systems
are providing that sort of consolation
to people what this means is that
the ways in which the ultimate questions
are being framed
and the ultimate realities that
philosophy is supposed to be getting to
are really quite arbitrary capricious
contingent they are not absolute
they are not universal they're not even
possessing
enough generality they may feel that way
to people who are working on them but
that's not really the case
here we come to the crux of it have we
actually made any progress
on these these ultimate you know
questions
and shusta says no and he says so at a
couple different points
so here's a great section
chapter 51 of part one
he tells us that the so-called ultimate
questions troubled mankind and the
world's dawn as badly as they trouble us
now
so even when we're you know looking at
things in a non-philosophical way
looking at these origin stories now he
picks you know adam and eve and cain and
abel
but we could take any mythology that we
want there are
fundamental questions being framed
and addressed there he says adam and eve
wanted to know
so they plucked the fruit at their risk
cain whose sacrifice did not please god
raised his hand against his brother and
it seemed to him he committed murder
in the name of justice in vindication of
his own
injured rights this question of justice
is an
ultimate one he goes on and he says
nobody has ever been able to understand
why god preferred abel's sacrifice to
that of cain and this is something
that's kind of interesting
if you think about the way that this
story is told
you know in catechism or in in our
popular culture don't be like
cain you know he's a bad guy and if you
read the biblical story
you'll see that cain gets angry and god
asks him why have you grown angry and
why is your face fallen and he also
warns cain he says
you've got to master sin it's lying at
the door it will master you if you don't
so there's a little bit more to the
story
than that but he kane you know just his
response is to go out and kill abel
and then of course we have the where's
your brother i'm not my brother's keeper
all that sort of stuff right raises
other questions
but the fundamental question is
why did god favor abel over
cain what was fair about that
you know wouldn't god know what was
going to happen if he did that shouldn't
he have given better counsel these are
ultimate questions of justice and we're
no closer
to answering these whether it's about
cain some some mythological person
way back in the past or whether it's
about questions of justice right now
questions of justice are tangled and he
goes on and he says
everything right now is being unriddled
and explained if we compare our
knowledge with those of the ancients we
appear
very wise but we're no nearer
to solving the riddle of eternal justice
than cain was
progress civilization all the conquests
of the human mind have brought us
nothing
new here like our ancestors we stand
still with fright and perplexity before
ugliness
disease misery senility death all that
the wise men have been able to do so far
is to turn the earthly horrors
into problems into things that we could
solve
and you know over a hundred years have
passed since
chestnut wrote these down haven't we you
know learned a lot about the human body
and about the brain and about how to
arrange society
aren't we so much more advanced than the
people he's talking about
now according to chest off yes we're
advanced and
our technology has gotten better we
haven't figured out the
the eternal riddle of justice it still
bedevils us
it's still there so
this is uh this is a a real issue here
he says uh the modern educated man with
the wisdom of all the centuries of
mankind at his command
knows no more about it than the old
singer who solved the universal problems
at his own risk
we the children of a moribund
civilization we old men from our birth
are in this respect as young
as the first man he has another
passage where he says something quite
similar
uh this is uh here we go
pair this uh chapter 66 part one in the
ultimate
questions of life we are not a bit
nearer the truth than our ancestors were
everyone knows it and yet so many go
talking about infinity without any hope
of ever saying
anything so this is going to be you know
an important part
where we'll get to what we ought to do
and actually let me jump forward a
little bit here
he says instinct doesn't mock it ignores
the wise
leads us by impossible ways to ends our
divine reason would hold absurd if it
could only see them
in time but reason is always lagging
behind we can't just rely
on reason to make progress in these
matters
a bit earlier in chapter 28
he also tells us about literature
right i mentioned this before literature
deals with these most
difficult and important problems of
existence and because of this
literatures consider themselves the most
important of people he doesn't just mean
people
writing literature he means people using
literature he means people
who talk about literature who
tell other people about what the
literature actually
means and so you know should we just uh
have a sort of pessimism we can't really
understand anything
we can understand some things but when
it comes to ultimate questions we can't
really make any progress
well we still have to figure out what
we're going to do
in our life in relation to things so
just does provide us some advice
and some useful responses one is very
early on and this is in chapter nine
part one he says we know nothing of the
ultimate realities of our existence nor
shall we ever know anything let that be
agreed
so very pessimistic or skeptical
point of view what should we do so he
goes on and he says
doesn't follow that therefore we must
accept some or other dogmatic theory as
a
way of living not even positivism which
has such a skeptical
face on it it only follows that we are
free to change our conception of the
universe as often as we change
our boots or gloves and that constancy
of principle belongs only to one's
relationships with other people in order
that they may know
where and to what extent they may depend
on us on principle we should respect
order in the external world
and chaos in the inner and so
this is one possible solution to it we
say we're gonna go after these ultimate
realities but we're going to do it in
our own way we're not going to expect
anybody else to understand what we're
doing
i think there's another really helpful
discussion in
chapter 122 about the difference between
knowing and understanding he tells us
that the effort to understand
people or life or the universe prevents
us from getting to know them
at all and so he cautions us against a
a deep problem to know and to understand
are two concepts which are not only
non-identical but just the opposite of
one another
in meaning we think we've understood a
phenomenon if we've included it in a
list of others previously
known to us and so it could be that we
can't actually
understand these ultimate questions
in the sense that he's talking about
their classifying them
turning them into problems maybe in fact
to lose sight of them
but we that doesn't mean that we can't
know anything in relation to them
and as a matter of fact perhaps leaving
behind the concern about understanding
would be a way to allow ourselves to
get to to know them in a more
existential
intimate particular way he also tells us
that we shouldn't wait for ultimate
truths
uh from philosophy this is in uh
chapter 40 of of part two
says that that's a mistake it says
people go to philosophers for general
principles
philosophers supply them what sense is
there in them
none at all nature demands individual
creative activity from us people don't
understand this so they wait forever for
the ultimate truth
from philosophy which they will never
get and so instead he says
grow up be an adult find your own
ways of approaching it he says why
should not every grown-up person be a
creator
live in his own way at his own risk
and have his own experience
so you know this is advocating a very
experimental
attitude towards life finally
going back to that section where he was
talking about the europeans
and the russians and the contrast
between them
in chapter 45 after talking about this
confident truthfulness
he comes down and he says
[Music]
only we find unendurable a rhetoric
which poses his truth
and a truthfulness which would appear
cultured such a masquerade would try to
make us believe
that truth which is only limitedness has
a real
objective existence which is offensive
until the contrary is proved we need to
think that only one assertion
has or can have any objective reality
and what is that
nothing on earth is impossible you know
the title of the work
all things are possible this is the sort
of converse of it
nothing on earth is impossible every
time someone wants to force us to admit
that there are other more limited and
limiting truths
we must resist with every means we can
lay our
hands on and so this would be
a way of structuring our approach to
these ultimate questions
we can't get away from them we can't
resolve them
they are you could say part of the human
condition
you